[Music]
hey guys it's justine and today we're
checking out the brand new drone by dji
this is the brand new dgi mini 3 pro and
i am such a huge fan of dji and one of
the things that i'm most excited about
this drone is the fact that it is so
small so portable so compact and it
still comes in at under 249 grams which
means you don't have to register this
with the faa so i have the drone and i
also have their fly more kit plus so
this comes with a bunch of accessories
with the charger batteries propellers
and of course the mini three pro
controller not included so in comparison
to the previous version this has
improved battery life intelligent
features video transmission and a fully
upgraded imaging system and visual
sensing system now one of the most
important things to note is the weight
of this drought is 249 grams which is
under the weight limit that you would
need to actually register with the faa
it has a one and one third image sensor
that supports hdr it has three
directional obstacle sensing and an
upgraded pilot assistant system now the
battery you can get up to 34 minutes of
flight time but if you have the
intelligent flight battery plus you will
actually get 47 minutes of flight time
that is just absurd this is also able to
transmit up to 12 kilometers and it
features some of my favorite intelligent
shooting features like focus track time
lapse master shots and this also brings
back the possibility of vertical
shooting so tick tock you guys better
get ready for some incredible drone
shots all right let's unbox
the drone first i have to be very
careful with knives because i'm on blood
thinners
that far away
oh look at this
[Music]
oh wait a minute
i thought the controller didn't come
with it
oh my goodness
what a treat this is
i thought that was just like hey so like
you can use this pro controller with it
but no
excuse me
look at this
wow
oh we're
we're going out to fly tonight oh this
is so good look at that
tonight we fly baby
that's
[Music]
nice propellers
oh look at this
a little a little screwdriver
some paperwork
a little pamphlet of don't be a drone
idiot
this is very exciting i did not really
the controller game with it oh my
goodness i love this
all right little drone let's see what
you look like
very carefully use my knife
oh this actually looks different than
the previous version oh it looks like a
little alien spaceship
look how freaking cute this is like i
can actually put this in my yoga pants
no joke
i have pockets like not actually like in
my like yoga pants pockets just
breakfast charge to activate wait is the
battery in here already wait there can't
be a battery in this
oh my god this is the battery this is so
freaking light
get out of here obviously flight times
do vary depending upon your weather
conditions so if it is really windy
you're gonna get a little less flight
time because the drone is having to do a
little bit more work to compensate for
how windy it is but
wow
i just can't believe
how small this is i mean the controller
is heavier than this
wow the one that's interesting is you
actually do need to screw the propellers
in normally they just kind of pop into
place so that's kind of interesting that
they decided to go that route which i
mean like i don't hate it unless
i
run into a tree and i need to change out
my props
let's see what is in our fly more kit
plus box
[Music]
nice little
bag love that
okay we've got
some extra batteries here
i would love this little charging dock
too
how cool
that's nice
[Music]
oh something's in here
oh more
propellers
additional cabling
oh we're going to be so sad what's in
here
[Music]
some more
instructionals so these are the upgraded
batteries that will give you a longer
flight time but as you can see this on
here says this is the ultra light
version of the battery so this is how
you'll be able to stay under that 249
grams but if you do use the upgraded
batteries that's where you are going to
need to register your drone so you know
it's kind of like one of those little
gray areas but if you do want to fly
longer and use these additional
batteries you will still need to
register it
so
that being said
i'm going to charge these batteries up
update my firmware and get this all set
up and go out and fly okay we're out and
about and inside of my little baggie
here
is a drone and a controller and two
batteries i know it's freaking awesome
we're down here in venice it is actually
pretty busy it's a friday night we're
gonna take off see how this little drone
flies this looks like a nice spot
yeah
i love having this integrated screen in
the controller like that's super
exciting
so small
[Music]
uh
so
[Music]
do
all right so i switched the camera to
vertical
let's get ourselves a tick tock
[Music]
i'm a professional let me live let me
live my life so honestly my first flight
with this was really awesome it's
actually pretty windy today at the beach
and this thing handled it like a
freaking
champion i also didn't even put a full
100 battery in this i had already done
firmware updates before i left the house
so it's kind of wild that this lasted a
very very long time so i swapped
batteries and now i'm going to take some
photos first i'm going to take a photo
there's a sphere 180 wide angle and
vertical so let's take a sphere photo
and there it is oh my gosh it looks so
cool
i'm saving that
[Music]
so this was so far out there getting
these shots of these boats and it was so
windy on shore i can only imagine it was
even more windy out there and this thing
handled like a champ like i didn't even
feel like it was struggling at all so
all things considered
this little guy is so awesome i
absolutely love it and i just love how
small portable compact i love this
controller i'm so excited to take this
with me pretty much everywhere which i
don't really
really go anywhere but next time i do
you're coming with me
thank you guys so much for watching i
hope you guys enjoyed this if you
haven't already subscribed to my channel
please hit subscribe and be sure to hit
like leave me some comments below and
hit the bell so you'll be notified when
i post new videos i'm freaking freezing
i love you bye
[Music]
we did it